il m'a bonsoir acte 63 donc des gilets
jaunes qui touche à sa fin quelle est
l'ambiance au sein du cortège
eh bien écoutez olivier l'ambiance est
parfaitement calme ici pour le moment
d'autant plus que les forces de l'ordre
sont appelées à se disperser les forces
de l'ordre ont sonné la fin de cette
manifestation qui est arrivé ici à la
fin donc de son parcours au croisement
de l'avenue de villiers de villiers et
du boulevard de courcelles un comptage
qui sait qui c'est une manifestation qui
s'est déroulée sans encombre sens
absolument aucun incident au plus fort
de cette manifestation on pouvait
compter environ 2000 personnes ils sont
en ce moment même
ne reste plus que quelques centaines de
gilets jaunes tout au plus et je suis
justement avec sébastien
qui a participé à cette manifestation
aujourd'hui qui manipule participé à de
nombreux autres samedi et sébastien
bonsoir est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer quel était le mot d'ordre de
cette manifestation aujourd'hui alors
que le projet de réforme a été présentée
en conseil des ministres le projet de
réforme des retraites alors en préambule
j'aimerais déjà on peut présenter j'ai
51 ans je n'ai jamais manifesté de ma
vie est là sur 63 samedi
j'ai manifesté 61 samedi pour exprimer
une colère
là vous parlez de la retraite mais ce
n'est pas que la retraite avant la
retraite c'est la démocratie
dès l'instant que citoyen à la
démocratie et à son mot à dire
on peut s'exprimer sur beaucoup de
sujets donc ça fait 61 samedi donc sur
les 63 comme je disais à dénoncer et à
exprimer ma colère en tant que citoyen
qui est inacceptable
on a un gouvernement qui nous ment loi
après loi réforme après réforme il y à
des mensonges absolus comme la edouard
philippe disait tout le monde sera
gagnant pour les retraites mais non tout
le monde sera perdant peut-être sauf les
agriculteurs donc c'est c'est comme ça
est ce que vous trouvez normal vous êtes
papa vous avez un enfant on vous oblige
11 vaccins obligatoires
est-ce que vous pensez que le ce
mouvement veut peut continuer comme ça
jusque jusqu'aux prochaines élections
par exemple présidentielle est ce que
vous pensez qu'il peut y avoir encore de
galles
nombreuses nombreuses manifestations bah
écoutez comme je me suis engagé semaine
dernière sur une autre chaîne 63 samedi
ça peut être 65 70 100 200 300 s'il faut
que je meure à 90 cents manifestations
je ne m'arrêterai pas et vous pensé
puisque la localité en ce moment la
gronde sociale vient surtout de ce
projet de réforme de retraite vous
pensez qu'il peut encore être retirés
vous pensez que la contestation peut
avoir gain de cause et qu'il est il est
possible que ce projet soit soit annulée
alors si on est dans la rue oui je pense
quand même mais il faut impérativement
plus de personnes dans la rue c'est
indispensable
une fois des millions dans la rue merci
beaucoup sébastien avec nous hier
enveloppe vous le voyez les forces de
l'ordre sont en train d'évacuer les
derniers manifestants voulaient que ça
bouge un petit peu excusez moi peut-être
peut-être voilà peut-être avoir un
nouveau l'image donc l'alm effet son est
définitivement terminée et donc les
manifestants s'en vont en grande et vous
mercredi mercredi prochain pour une
nouvelle manifestation sur la réforme
des retraites et samedi prochain pour
une pour à nouveau samedi jaune
merci beaucoup guillemat pour ces
précisions en guise marosi en direct du
cortège